We talked a bit about this earli
The Arkansas governor, Sarah
Huckabee Sanders, on the job
just shy of a month, delivered
the Republican response last nig
Often
these addresses
are try to speak to the country
present your alternative
to the president in power, in th
a Democrat in power.
But Sarah
Huckabee Sanders
seemed to be talking very narrow
to the Republican base.
He's the first man to surrender
his presidency
to a woke mob
that can't even tell you what a
Whether Joe Biden believes this
or is simply too weak to resist
His administration
has been completely hijacked
by the radical left
Fact check, bizarre.
All right.
You know,
these are notorious things
anyway, to pull off the rebuttal
Obviously,
I think she has national
political ambitions and is setti
trying to set herself up for tha
It was pretty dark.
Yeah.
Everything that was interesting
is that in addition
to really playing the Republican
she made a very clear
generational argument.
She spoke about the fact that at
she's the youngest governor
that President Biden is 80 calle
for a new generation
of Republican leadership.
Not clear
what that means in terms of 2024
and her former boss President Tr
if there's any
she paid tribute to him in the s
she did trip
he made to Iraq and good
for the commander in chief at th
Donald Trump for visiting troops
Most commanders in chief do that
it was just kind of an odd.
And even though she's young she
has these kind of retro ideas
about America. Right.
I mean she's going after drag qu
she's going after
Nixon saying it can't be any
in any documents in Arkansas.
I don't think it is anyway
going after CRT.
You know,
they are really trying to tear
Joe Biden,
as, you know, a member of the wo
Joe Biden is 80 years old.
He's a white male.
It's very hard to do that, I thi
But they are going to keep tryin
and I think
it doesn't stick as
easily to Joe Biden
as it would have to like Hillary
or Barack Obama.
But this is kind of
what Republicans have done.
I think it's less and less effec
going forward.
I think cultural wars
have worked for them in the past
I think they're not as effective
I think the question is,
who's your intended audience?
If you want to appeal to a niche
and raise money from a niche,
it can be very effective
if you want to become a presiden
of the United States, less so pe
Another drama is the fight.
Again, you're watching the presi
on the ground
in Madison, Wisconsin, is betwee
President Biden.
It's Rick
Scott,
the Republican senator from Flor
It was his Social Security plan
the president was referencing la
He said he wasn't going to name
while Rick Scott
instead of taking offense
or instead of saying,
I've moved away from my plan, sa
bring it on. Mr.
President, with this ad,
the president's about to go to F
Scott, say, here's an ad
he wants to close
the loophole and raise your taxe
I'm Rick Scott. Biden should res
I approve this message.
Ron DeSantis
is your candidate of choice
in the presidential race out of
Rick Scott has been bumped off
a committee by Mitch McConnell
because he challenged
Mitch McConnell in the Senate.
What is Rick Scott?
You know, that extremely intrigu
character
because he leads the Senate Repu
he loses his seat
and he tries to become leader.
And now he's going to get into t
with Joe Biden.
I think
if you asked Mitch McConnell, he
prefer that Rick Scott resign
rather than president by.